we begin tonight with more tensions
between russia and nato russia says that
it is suspending its diplomatic mission
to nato and closing the moscow offices
of the western military alliance
russia's foreign minister sergey lavrov
announced the move today saying russia's
office in brussels where nato is
headquartered
would close on the first of november
he said the move is in retaliation to
nato's expulsion of several russian
delegates who were suspected
of
the closure marks a new low in relations
between nato and russia let's listen to
what the russian foreign minister said
earlier today
due to the deliberate steps by nato
there are almost no proper conditions
for the basic diplomatic activities and
in response to nato's actions we are
suspending the activities of our
permanent mission to nato including the
work of our main military representative
all right dws brussels correspondent
terry schultz she is covering this story
for us good evening to you terry this
looks like
at this stage this is just diplomatic
tit for tat is that what it is and have
we had a reaction from nato tonight
certainly brent moscow warned that when
nato announced it would kick out eight
russian diplomats accusing them of
spying that there would be a retaliation
and what moscow called at that time
asymmetrical retaliation and that's
what's happened now
at a political level you know nato and
moscow haven't really been talking much
so it might seem that this doesn't have
a huge practical implication but in
reality there have been three military
staff from nato stationed in moscow
keeping military to military
communications open and my sources say
that's going to be a real loss when
these three people are kicked out the
end of the month would you take a listen
to what the german foreign minister
heiko moss what he said today about the
situation
this makes everything more difficult and
the situation is already difficult
this will extend even further the phase
of icy relations
i believe that when it comes to nato
where we are dealing with military
issues
and with security issues
this is anything but helpful
this will seriously damage relations
so terry we heard it right there from
the german foreign minister saying that
this will seriously damage nato russian
relations is that how it's being seen
within the confines of nato
certainly it doesn't help although nato
russian relations were already pretty
much at a low point
the russian delegation has been
downsized forcibly by nato a couple of
times since 2014
and so
you know there really hasn't been much
dialogue russia didn't ever replace its
ambassador to to nato now for years uh
but certainly as a heiko moss says this
doesn't help
nato for its part um is blaming russia
for the problem and saying it does
remain open to dialogue and has been
inva has been inviting the kremlin to
hold a meeting with with nato and nato
russia council as it's called for the
last 18 months and has not gotten a
positive response from moscow so yeah
the spiral is on a downward trend but
it's not one that started with this
all right our very own terry schultz
with the ladies tonight from brussels
terry as always thank you
you